okay we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p a
couple weeks ago i mentioned that i in
here in boston I'm part of a
cryptocurrency group and one of the
things that sometimes happens is I
participate in a poker game where the
buy-in is paid for with cryptocurrency
and someone left me the following
voicemail about that um hey David so you
recently mentioned that you're in a
poker group in Boston um I hope you know
that gambling is illegal in the state of
Massachusetts and that I hope you're
really not part of some kind of like a
legal gambling ring or something that
sounds really sketchy and yeah you know
you might have not you probably
shouldn't have mentioned that you know
anyway Bart this is pretty suspicious
yeah very very suspicious how is yeah
how can we say gambling is illegal if we
have casinos coming to massachusett or
maybe it means that unlicensed on yeah I
don't know in any case I have nothing
further to say about it I should have
muted my headphones because now I feel
like I'm implicated in all of this just
by having heard me say that it's all uh
yeah it's so it's all fake money right I
mean cryptocurrency is not actual money
so there was no real gambling taking
place or something like that
on the bonus show today we will talk
about a youtuber under fire after
posting a video showing an apparent
suicide victim and the implications with
regard to the YouTube universe of that
uber for blood in Rwanda delivery robots
that work kind of like uber to deliver
life-saving blood to people in need and
Amazon is buying Amazon could not
possibly be buying target right well I
don't know we will talk about that on
the bonus show as well david pakman.com
slash membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show those were the two ways to
get access to the bonus show we will
speak to you then